We have all experienced the phenomenon of dijafu, which is the strange feeling we feel when entering
Room or exposure to a new position and say to yourself "I've been here before.
I feel like everything here is familiar. "
It has been shown that we can stimulate some forms of dijafu towards subjects of experience. Therefore
There is a theory that the Deja vu produces scattered memories
We stored them in our minds, and these memories can be retrieved by moving around
It's like something we've been through before. So we do not have to call the universes
Parallel. We do not have to call several universes to explain most of the cases of digavo.
However, this raises a question about mobility between
Several universes are different by any measure and the answer to this is not fairly clear.
We physicists believe that there are several actual universes within
Living room. We are vibrating waves operating in a dial, and these waves
Vibrate and break up over time
The Nobel Prize winner Steve Weinberg is on the radio.
If you are in your living room and listen to the radio (BBC) radio was set to one frequency,
But in the living room there are several radio frequencies for stations (Cuba) and (Moscow) and stations
Other, all these radio frequencies vibrate inside the living room, while
The radio is set to one frequency only
Now, in other words when there are two adjacent universe, they are coherent and you can move
Between them and back. But in time, these two worlds separate and begin
Vibration at different frequencies. They may not come together again. So why
Your radio inability to listen to Moscow Radio? Why can not you have your radio
Listen to all frequencies? Since the radio has been disconnected and is no longer vibrating
In harmony with these other frequencies.
The same is true of quantum physics. We are atoms and these atoms are vibrating, but they are
No longer vibrating in perfect harmony with these other universes. We have separated from them
And we became in isolation from them. In other words, the DiJavo is probably only scattered memories
Inside our minds recall memories and previous positions scattered. However, in quantum physics,
There really are some certain parallel universes surrounding us, and the problem is that we can not enter it.
Because we have become isolated from them and are no longer vibrating in harmony with them.
Sorry for that.